now back to washington and to an event
hosted by president biden to celebrate
the passage of new gun reform
legislation an event interrupted by a
protester demanding that the president
actually do more to stop the epidemic of
violence
sit down you'll hear what i have to say
let him talk let him talk no one okay
the man trying to talk there is manuel
oliver his son was killed in the 2018
high school shooting in parkland florida
he was escorted out of the event but you
the sentiment there is clear meanwhile
the families of victims in uvalde texas
are still looking for answers as well
after the deadly shooting in their
community lilia luciano has more now
from yuvaldi
change their lives
so our teachers and children can go to
school safe
vincent salazar's 11 year old
granddaughter laila was among the 19
children and two teachers massacred on
may 24th and i cry
every night
she is not here
and she is not here because
our system from texas failed us
activists including the chicano movement
brown berets families and friends of the
victims walked from rob elementary
school to the town square for the
unheard voices of the march and rally
organized by the family of nine-year-old
victim jacqueline casares we will not be
silent until we know our kids and
teachers did not die in vain state
newspapers have published screen grabs
of surveillance video from inside the
school showing officers waiting in the
hallways for 77 minutes as a shooter
attacked despite being armed with at
least 13 rifles and ballistic shields
the uvalde mayor state lawmakers and the
texas department of public safety have
all insisted the public should have
access to that video but the uvalde
district attorney is stopping its
release citing the ongoing investigation
i challenge
all of you
cowards
that were in
that class
in that hallway
to step
down that parkland parent who spoke out
during president biden's bill signing
yesterday said you cannot be polite with
gun violence because gun violence is not
polite with you the president said he
does support further action including
reinstating a federal assault weapons
ban but that is far from popular here in
texas even in this very community of
yuvaldi
so a lot of people want to see that
happen thank you very much lilia